for those of you don't know me I'm J I'm
Josh Vidal I'll be here for five six
days and then I'm out of here but I
figured I would show some of my games
from the tournament mostly because I was
busy playing the tournament it wasn't
preparing lectures so I figured out at
least show the games but okay so this
was the game against grave at this point
I was winless I lost my first game kind
of unfortunate fashion and then I drew I
think three or four games in a row so I
was kind of itching for a win I didn't
know if I would get it but so again I
mean this guy kind of plays a lot of
openings different stuff I didn't really
know what to expect so I decided to
start with Knight f3 which is a kind of
a movie if you want to play quietly this
is a nice move to start with and it's a
little tricky as I was explaining
earlier because black doesn't really
know what pawn you're gonna put in the
center oftentimes I'll play this putt
next
sometimes I'll play this one next and
once in a while I'll play this one so
black doesn't really know how you're
gonna try to control the center what
you're gonna do maybe I'll even just
fianchetto next so in this game he plays
this move which is of course perfectly
fine but the question is which pawn do I
choose now and he guesses not like one
is much better than other but yeah I
actually played efore the only for for a
number of years I actually only switched
to other moves maybe in the last few
years so but the thing is these days I
don't play it as much so it was actually
a little bit of a surprise probably to
my opponent that I put my pawn here now
but okay he just continues developing
play this move I play d4
ah maybe although he didn't show me
accelerated dragons so not as much
yes infinitely they're always
transpositions how do you play here
we're in a Sicilian now accelerated
dragon with g6 right so there's native
three is a very tricky move because it
can transpose to many different setups
many different openings but as I was
explaining earlier in my in the beginner
lecture as its called
actually you probably won't get in too
much trouble if you control the center
and and develop your pieces and get
castled for the most part it's hard to
get in trouble if you do all those
things so again so I'm controlling the
center d6 so okay I want to develop how
I like to play but okay
some I'm playing again I someone now a
normal person probably would play what
move most of the time 96
maybe I mean you have to watch out for
the night getting attacked but I don't
nobody five if you play see if I ever I
might take and then take trade Queens
put his King on d8 I mean it's probably
a little uncomfortable for blood yeah
develop is peace prepare to Castle I'd
probably play here prepare to castle
normal game right but okay I'm playing
grave so he plays a six now is there
anything true horribly wrong with this
move no but what is it not do though um
one of the things I like to tell my
students and I kind of like to emphasize
it it is that no matter what openings
you're playing or what you're doing you
want to follow at least general opening
principles a little bit so develop your
pieces control the center regardless I
don't care if you're playing some gambit
you want to get your pieces you still
want to control the center it doesn't
matter what you're playing so if you
have specific knowledge and you like
some system where you don't do this okay
but for the most part if you do this you
will almost never get in trouble I'd say
nine times out of ten you'll be
perfectly good maybe more if you don't
do these things even half the time you
might end up busted
opening and it's never Pleasant you want
to play a chess game right but okay so
he plays a six so again follow some
principles what am I gonna play
I have several fine moves here so don't
feel like you have to find one in
particular Bishop c4 looks okay I didn't
like it because at some point he might
play b5 and attack my bishop with temple
right but probably not a terrible move
remember don't think too hard at this
point like there are lots of good
answers I could play a for preventing b5
but again not a central move I wanted a
central move it should be three a nice
central move I like it now what I played
that's been said but the problem is b5
attacks my bishop yeah didn't want to do
with it Bishop f4 is probably also fine
any developing move is good I happened
to put my bishop on e2 the main reason
is because I wanted to put it here but I
was worried he might try and move like
this and I wasn't sure about this pawn I
didn't want that pawn to be loose so I
put my bishop here instead but again
probably anything's fine so he played
Knight here again I don't exactly know
what he's doing I would either play b5
her bring my night out or something
right but no he no interest in doing
that so okay so what do I do
faced with such a ridiculous looking do
I try to okay it's obviously not that
bad but do I try to rush them in the
center now just Castle
so he plays a real fighting move just
kidding so now so now I have again many
options 8:4 is perfectly fun maybe it's
even the simplest option but ok I didn't
want to push any pawns I just wanted to
develop my pieces and control the center
but here I have a particularly nice
option because I can actually develop a
piece with temple yeah I always look for
moves which are temple moves pretty much
any GM you ask will always look for them
so the nice thing about this move is it
kind of makes black decide what he wants
to do with all these pieces like is he
gonna put his knight here isn't gonna
put it here what's he gonna do and I it
makes him make this decision and I'm
putting the bishop on a nice square so
it's kind of a nice move so he puts his
knight here he's gonna do a setup which
is actually called the hippo not even
joking which is where he puts the nice
here and pawn here and Bishop here
so I played queen up which is a pretty
standard move not necessary I mean I
could have played a four here as well
which is always a fine move just to
control his Queen side but okay nothing
wrong with Queen d2 so he plays h6 he
could castle but then the problem is he
can never ever kick my bishop away and I
might trade off his Bishop and then try
to attack him so he didn't really want
that so he plays here so I go back here
so why would I go back here by the way
kind of an interesting question I want
to prevent him from doing what if he
wants to push his pawns on the Kings
side feel free he doesn't have much
development and he has no pieces that
can come over here the nice thing about
controlling the center is that it's hard
for your opponent to actually activate
their pieces so if he wants to try to
shove these pawns he can feel free but I
mean how is he gonna get his pieces out
right so I wasn't afraid of that but I
didn't want him to play a nice
developing move what's a nice developing
move usually the conclusion of your
development castle y candy castle now
all right someone's awake good yeah so
Bishop will take here so now you just
can't castle so what's he gonna do
so you actually played a knight here
so here's a mini threat I'd say a mini
threat not anything hugely bad but
something I'd rather not alone
yeah I'd rather he doesn't take my
bishop right because again I want to
prevent him from castling so I played
here now I actually want to pause for a
second because he doesn't have to play
here the you're so hip I'll had it set
up for something like this so let's even
give him these two moves for free
because I feel like it now say I bring
clean pieces in the center whatever so a
position like this it looks kind of
entertaining if you have this kind of
weird symmetrical position you have the
bishops here you have the Knights here
so your Knights are in the center your
bishops are controlling the center you
have most of your pieces out but what is
what is the drawback of a setup like
this there are some players especially
you know I'm sure you guys have played
some called players who like to do weird
setups like every game right but usually
if you think really hard you can find a
drawback to mostly setups what are the
drawbacks to this particular setup why
is the hippo called the hippo and not a
cooler animal what he doesn't control
okay it's hard to get the pieces of good
squares why is that the case
I control more of the center I have more
space in the center to be more I mean
he's still controlling the center but
he's only controlling his half I'm
controlling all of my half plus a little
bit of his half right so he can't
improve his pieces as much as I can
there's something else which I'd like
you to note which has to do with that
what do most openings do that the hippo
does not that's that's a very part of it
you'll notice in most openings where
there's a problem of space and this is
true in standard openings too for
example how many of you guys have played
the Queens gambit declined one of the
oldest openings standard
what is your problem piece in the Queens
gambit declined usually not usually
right yeah we play the Kali is white the
bishops the problem yeah the Queens
gambit declined is why and it's but
basically there are many openings where
the Queen is actually your problem piece
you can get out all your pieces all
these pieces are out the rooks don't
come out anyway but you can't get your
Queen out and your queen is actually the
problem piece yeah there are lots of
openings where this is the
because you want your queen you don't
want your queen sitting on the back rank
you'd like it maybe on c7 but if he
tries to play this move he's gonna get
blasted in the center because I have
more space than he does so the queen is
a problem piece but what what didn't
black do at the very beginning of the
game for example if the game had gone
Knight f3 d5 he would have already done
it on move 1 it's been probably how many
moves about 10 moves and he still hasn't
done it which is what what is d5 dude
that none of his moves have done not
attack the center bishops are attacking
the center there are two things that you
want to do in the opening this is
something which you know you could tell
beginners but you can also tell advanced
players and oftentimes some people don't
know this but what it is is you want to
attack you attack or control the center
but you also want to do what occupy the
center that's what I was looking for
which means usually putting pawns in the
center so pawns here I'm occupying the
center he is not and that is why I have
a very nice space advantage now keep in
mind this is not you know say class a
player playing back or at twelve-hundred
this is a top GM I think he's 2 or 3 in
the country something like this and he's
still playing its way so but the point
is that even doesn't matter for GM's
playing this way or 1600 or a beginner
it's always there always drawbacks now
doesn't mean he's gonna roll over and
die no I actually won this game but it
took me 75 minutes so I didn't win
kutzle opening either I mean we ended up
in some weird position eventually where
he was okay so it doesn't mean you're
gonna just win the game but what it
means is that out of the opening they're
gonna be a lot less comfortable and
you're gonna have some really nice
chances but ok let's continue with what
actually happens because it was kind of
interesting and I think it shows the
drawback to this setup a lot because
actually I didn't quite get the setup I
want it right away
but he played here which is a kind of a
tricky move because you want this so I'm
like no sir
right I have all the time in the world
so
he plays b5 he wants to try to attack my
name so he's gonna threaten when he
attacks my knight what's the main
problem I have where do I put it and
also the thing is when you grab the
center early in openings where you grab
the center early and your opponent does
not often they're trying to attack your
center right and the whole thing is like
if they can attack your center or maybe
win a pawn or damage it in some way that
often justifies their play so what is
black trying to attack which part of my
center
efore so if he plays before I have no
longer have a defender so okay I put my
bishop here but so what I can reposition
and now I defend the pawn and I also
give my net a square so I can jump this
way the black plays here he's like no no
I'm still gonna attack your net so here
I actually found a good move
I'm talking like it's a rare thing and
sometimes it is but I think this was
actually a very good move so I could
play a move like a three but a little
lame so what do you what other moves do
I have to prevent before before all
right you're two for two so why is this
move what do I like this move other than
the fact I played it I don't usually
always like the moves I plan but in this
case yes who did oh yeah I think so good
move all right if s agrees it has to be
good so why is this move good what does
it do besides prevent before yeah it
controls his pawns completely like
basically his pawns are now a mobile but
aside from all that it threatens
something and this is something I talked
about earlier do you remember what I
said what kind of moves do I like over
tempo moves are good but it also moves
that do more than one thing right
multi-purpose moves so if you have a
multi-purpose move I almost always like
that over a move that does one thing a3
is a single-purpose move but
before before grab space prevents before
and actually makes a positional threat
so usually in the hippo they put their
pawn here which looks kind of silly
right but the whole point is that it's
hard to attack them when their pawns are
like this with the pawn here it gives me
an attacking move a for my goodness
three for three I'm gonna be a GM in
like two months
oh yeah alright so a four and I'm
breaking up his pawns right so if he
takes my pawn I take his all of a sudden
here's a weakness and keep in mind he
can't move his pieces around so if he
has one weakness he's probably just
gonna lose the pawn because he can't
move his pieces anywhere so he actually
finds kind of a clever move to defend it
although it's a very awkward looking
move Bishop here so what's he up to
why can't I play a four or maybe I can't
who knows did I play a four how many of
you want to play a force though how many
of you don't I knew it all right why not
a four
how exactly tomorrow I mean the guy is a
little crazy but he's a tricky guy he
has a purpose there's something he wants
to do so the bishop looks kind of
ridiculous here but at least he's
defending but there's something which if
your opponent ever plays the hippo or
some opening where they don't grab lots
of space they don't really fight for the
center there's something which you have
to remember if you could remember this
you can play his position super well I
actually know well because I grew up in
New England and one of the main the one
of the strongest players there was this
GM called alexander ivanov and he would
play setups like this not the hippo but
setups like this all the time and often
I would rush at him I trying to
checkmate him I'd do something and my
centre would get destroyed his pieces
would come flying at me and I'd lose
this happened to me many times but
eventually what I learned and once I
learned this he started playing normal
openings is that you take your time
you're never in a rush because you have
more space and you have more improving
moves than your opponent does so what
that means is you don't have to be in a
rush you know there's no there's no fire
nothing's happening but what piece
definitely can be improved mm-hmm so
where would you like it see 100 your
first wrong answer why did you want to
unsee one by the way and how are you
gonna not make this Hank you said
eventually so I'll give you partial
credit
but yeah the problem I thought founders
would see one was that I could never see
how to move these pieces that was my
main problem the position but I played
this move with the idea that one day I
might play my bishop moves defending my
pawn and then I can move them right see
what I mean so I was thinking about
moving my pieces at some point if I
could get my knife here and have this I
think black can safely resign because
this is like I mean I have the center I
have no weaknesses all my pieces are
aiming at him this would be great but
it's not so easy to get because my
Center is still so even here I was being
very cautious even though his setup
looks ridiculous
doesn't mean I can take advantage right
away so I played rook e1 Queen d7
so I decided that
he's controlling a four enough now I'm
not gonna play a four so what improve
your move do you think I play now it's a
very slight improvement but it doesn't
prove my position a little bit maybe a
three does it solidifies my pawns but
not what I chose in this particular
position whoa
see the problem is let's say I go at him
with a move like a five this is a good
example no no no no no forget the night
he could take if takes Knight then takes
Knight and then you lose a piece
actually yeah but it's okay he goes here
so now he's threatening my bishop if he
takes my bishop by the way he can cancel
if we trade pieces who is that good for
if you have more space do you want to
trade pieces no if you take here I open
up his bishop I give away my center you
see what I mean so it's an
understandable reaction you want to play
e5 you want to play d5 if you sometimes
it's good if the your opponent puts
pieces on bad squares sometimes you can
punish them with d5 or d5 but in this
case these moves only serve to weaken my
position I don't want any piece of them
I'm never gonna give him any relief if
he wants to play a move like this and
I'll play here okay this is the way he
wants it now actually here I'd probably
play 95 and just slaughter him somehow
but okay in previous positions I could
play e5 and he still has no room see
enemy but if he ever plays here then I
play d5 err I take and I open the center
on my terms when it's on my terms he's
gonna get killed if I try to thrust at
him like this with e5 or d5 he's
probably can end up on top or at least
with an okay position but again I have
no intention of moving my central pawns
for now no rush just chillin proving my
pieces so how could I improve my a1 rook
that's the piece I decided I decided I'm
not playing a four at the moment so
hmm I like him in the center two four
four four four five I'm keeping track of
your score if you get nine deeper if you
maintain 90% or better
you're like twenty four hundred strength
so yeah I'm giving him a special
certificate he gets to keep one of these
glasses oh I got a flip on all right so
you got broke 81 so he plays Bishop back
to b7 he's like all right I don't want
my Bishop on this stupid square I'll go
back now this improving moves been
suggested it's kind of mean in fact I
think of it as a mean move because it
shows I'm in no rush at all like I'm
never gonna rush this position 92 would
drop a pawn yeah it's okay no hurry at
all yeah yeah that's why I figured it's
not gonna help a three yeah when he saw
this move he was like shaking his head
he was like because he's not happy
because I'm not gonna come at him right
I'm just gonna slowly improve and the
problem is I can do this way longer than
he can how many improving moves can he
have his B he has no room for his pieces
so again guys guys who play like this
and okay Gary I've complained normal
openings to of course he's a very strong
player but when they play like this they
want you to go at them like like he said
about 20 miles right he likes it when
opponents go after him and try to punish
but you play patiently you just take the
center and kind of wait it out improve
your position eventually they run out of
moves and they're the ones who have to
go crazy and usually when they're the
ones going crazy and going at you when
you have all this space it's usually
very brutal so so I played a three and
at this point I think after a three he
was just frustrated so he's like all
right forget this
this is actually typical in the hippo
they try to do this with their king but
it takes forever and it shows that he's
not that all right I've had enough I'm
just gonna move my king so at least he's
trying to improve his position if he
gets his King here and rook out he's
improved right not much but
so once he played this move I was happy
playing here now there's a ring that I
didn't play this earlier any guesses g5
and then he can castle maybe or even
Knight h5 and if I go back then he
castles I didn't want him to castle but
he he decided all right enough is enough
but now no castling right so now I
improve my bishop by the way once my
bishop moves my knight can now move or
my bishop can move right so my pieces
are becoming more mobile remember it
once I improve my pieces enough he's
gonna be in big trouble so there's about
four King g8 very nice improving move
it's always nice when your opponent's
improving moves our King f8 King G it
makes you feel good about yourself so
how do i improve now again lots of
options there's no necessarily correctly
one of the things I didn't like this
bishops a little exposed I want to make
it nice and neat
tucked away yeah Bishop tation it's not
much but again what is black gonna do
incidentally I did have another purpose
with this move it wasn't just for that
if his King were to go here any idea
what my plans
maybe because now the situation has
changed first of all my bishop is
cutting along this diagonal so up here
is plays pawn takes pawn if he doesn't
if he lets me take this pawn I might be
able to win it the other thing is with
the King here say this happens so I can
throw in this trade or not but the point
is now I have this move and what's the
problem with the King here probably I'd
even go here first like there's no rush
right so now he has this pawn to defend
that's kind of an annoying pawn to
defend right also what's the problem
with this King Bishop lined up with the
King so all of a sudden he spent three
moves moving his King here but he kind
of walked into it right so he saw this
he was not happy with this so note how
I'm improving my position but I still
have some ideas right like after King h7
I wanted to have an idea to be able to
come after him a little bit right and I
may not even rush with e5 after King h7
I might start with h4 who knows probably
I'd go with e5 first but the other point
is that when his Knight moves here note
how my bishops away right he doesn't
attack it that's another nice thing
about this so here he really shocked me
this move was like out of left field
apparently e5 worried him so much he
played here so I didn't know what to
think of this one but it's like he's
just moving his piece away completely so
he moves a piece away from the center
and he blocks his King but okay he does
prevent any 500k when you see a move
like this again there's the temptation
you want to just kill him like I've the
fun I first saw this move I'm like okay
this has to be horrible I'm just gonna
go at him but then I realized wait a
second there's still no rush if this is
his improving move I do not have to
hurry right but what's the piece that I
always wanted to improve which before I
couldn't
yes this piece is blocking me it's
making it so I can't defend this con
it's just annoying so now I can move
that nitrite he took a piece away from
the center almost always when your
opponent takes a piece away from the
center there are consequences once in a
while justified of course but here I
mean okay this move is not terrifying me
right but now there's no more pressure
here I can play an 82 so here black
plays Knight c8 and at this point I was
like okay I've had enough I'm gonna go
at him but it was the wrong time I
actually have a maneuver here which
basically wins the game not wins the
game is then I'm gonna win right away
but as in his positions gonna be in
complete shambles and he'll have no kind
of play whatsoever so the key was I
wanted to improve this Knight right so I
played h4 going at him this move may be
not the best
it gives him some counter play he
actually gets back on the game a little
bit but I wanted to improve this Knight
but the problem I had was if I go here
okay it blocks my Bishop I'm not sure
about it if I go here it blocks my
Bishop again kind of annoying right if
my bishop were back here or it'd
actually be nice because now I could
just play here right but I didn't see a
nice way to regroup my pieces but there
was one option which I just completely
overlooked and it was very strong oh
it's very risky be careful no it's not
risky that's a chance all right I don't
want to improve my knight I want to
improve my name and I took away all the
options
tonight see one man 2,400 you're coming
where am I going with this guy and then
right so say he plays Knight b6 which
I'm assuming was this intention I play
Knight b3 so if you put this Knight here
he's probably just gonna end up losing
this pawn cuz I'll take and play Knight
a5 so okay say he moves his rook so that
after Knight a5 you can play Bishop here
what can I do now first of all one thing
which is really nice look at my pieces
they're all very beautifully coordinated
this bishop helps attack the center the
knight in Bishop pieces are in the
center they're very nice they control
everything and I don't have that awkward
c3 Knight now now it's on a5 so the
night of May 5 doesn't look that great
but it supports a very very nice brick
which is I don't think it supports d5
right and here I'm not taking any risks
I'm not letting his pieces into the game
right we're gonna end up exchanging and
how is he ever gonna defend his Queen
side so here once once things like say
this happens say pawn takes pawn Knight
takes Knight takes bishop day so what's
changed we've traded some pieces which
technically is good for him but here's
some severe problems now so the open C
file which could talk so I could target
which pawn alright I gave that one away
how about this one no one on the C file
yes now what other pawn is potentially
weak in his impact attacked so he has
two weaknesses and how many do I have
Zippo it's a pretty good situation right
best of all he is nothing he can do he
has a kid cheated in 1987 what's he
gonna do nothing so I could have gotten
this position with no Connor play and
basically I mean
okay I'd like to think I could win this
position easily considering this
tournament who knows there probably
would have been like six blunders and
somehow I'd end up winning but anyway so
this would have been was really nice but
unfortunately I was not as strong as our
kid in the sunglasses here it was told
it was told to me after the game and I'm
like oh yeah it's funny I saw the move
Knight c1 but I missed that after Knight
a5 I can play c4 actually it was Eugene
yeah my second told me dude you didn't
play Knight c1 what's wrong with you he
didn't say that but he basically said
that he's like yeah you were doing well
you played well and then you played h4
and then who knows but okay but you see
how what I missed really was that the
the c4 break though I thought my net an
a5 was like okay whatever
but the c4 break really clinches it cuz
then his Queen side collapses and all
his pieces are clumped up over here so
he's not really gonna be able to fight
for anything but here I decided to be
aggressive and attack him over here ah
yes it is yes nine eight seventy he
wanted I think he was worried about e5
it turns out night h7 not even so bad
because e5 was a real problem so he
wanted to move his knight but he doesn't
have any good squares he could have got
back to e8 but I think there were other
problems he probably was not happy but
yeah I mean I think that when he played
this opening he wasn't trying to just
like wow whatever I'll play the hippo
see what happens he was probably had in
mind that okay I want some position he
didn't want to walk into any preparation
I had and he certainly didn't I did not
prepare for this variation believe it or
not and he wanted just a fresh to
regional game so he could try to outplay
me in complications or I'll play me in a
position like this cuz okay I mean I was
he was seated to in the event and any
guess what I I was seated out of twelve
not to any guesses close
twelve so basically people playing me
not that I was a must-win game I wasn't
the last seed by a long stretch but I
was again I was a game they'd like to
win right so when you play this way
you're often trying to make it so that
you can try to win is black more easily
but at the same time it's a risk and
okay his risk was not paying off at this
moment even after h4 my positions still
quite good but it's at least a little
bit more complicated but anyway so here
I played Queen c1 which okay I mean I
wanted to walk out of a potential attack
probably probably not necessary but okay
I'm gonna fast forward these moves a
little bit so he brings his knight back
to the center because now I'm not
threatening me five kind of embarrassing
so I bring my knight out to f4 trying to
potentially attack him and defending my
pawn by the way so now some weird stuff
happens he attacks my bishop Thank You H
for forgiving his knight this square so
why you always have to be careful
pushing your pawns you can often regret
it now this move is not that horrible
right it's not like the Knights gonna
check me me but it's a little annoying
right his Knight is now has a safe
square that's not each seven right so I
play Bishop back I don't want to give
him my Bishop of course and he plays h5
so I solidify my Center I'm still not in
a rush even despite playing this semi
rushed move he plays Queen e7 I don't
ask what he's doing so I play Queen c2
once again slowly improving right note
how when I play slow improving moves
nothing bad happens when I try to rush
all of a sudden then he gets piece play
he gets stuff so look d8 here I found a
good move it's not one I'm gonna have
you fine because he I don't want you
guys to find these moves Knight h3
moving a piece away from the center
usually a bad idea here there's concrete
ideas which is that he was trying he was
planning to play e5 on me so when I play
here he if not what tempo anymore and
also in some positions I can play Bishop
here in at harass him it does open my
bishop as well so this move was actually
mine
looked better on f4 than it was so but
for the most part moving pieces away
from the center can get you into trouble
but okay he plays d5 now this position
is massively entertaining or at least it
could have been it wasn't entertaining
how I played I played it the most boring
way possible which was not terrible the
way I played it was kind of a human way
but at this point like we didn't have
tons of time so I played it kind of kind
of normal but apparently I have a win
here
so I could have played this move I was
looking at this move but I was like what
happens if black takes my d4 pawn you
guys are gonna tell me show me what I
did not see
because I looked at this and I just
couldn't find anything here but
apparently I had a very good move
Brooksie one
um well keep in mind I did sack up on
right and I gave away a central pawn
central pawns are usually quite a bit
more important than side pawns right so
I need something really good I wasn't
gonna play this unless I have a really
powerful move here so what am I gonna do
aha
opening up my bishop and apparently
after this move black is completely lost
so um let's say so for example I could
take with the bishop or the pawn I think
it's pretty similar let me just check
again this was told to me after the game
I haven't fully analyzed all my games
yet but yeah so let's say pawn takes
ah yeah this is nasty oh yeah okay so
say pond takes what now it is a tempting
move isn't it
so yeah let's give it a shot what could
be the worst that happened you're only
giving away a piece so can't pawn takes
Queen takes so if King f8 there's a very
simple move which is good a fork what's
the fourth that's a fork but more
importantly more importantly you're not
gonna win either the king of the rook
what are you gonna win the Queen that's
good apparently Bishop takes d5 has
probably been a better move and on that
note after Queen blocks what do you do
what fork what's going on what position
are we looking at all right guys this is
something that's very important when you
go like I realize you're sacrificing my
pieces and not your pieces keep track of
what pieces you're sacrificing if you
sacrifice a bishop and a pawn getting an
exchange back how big is that by the way
your trading queen is giving away your
attack you trade Queens and you're
taking a rook which I can take back what
do you think your position is gonna be
like after that keep in mind you gave up
you you did take a couple pawns but look
at how black's pieces all of a sudden
right so remember when you're
sacrificing keep track of what pieces
you're given away if you give meat it
doesn't matter you can give away all
your pieces but if you're only winning a
rook then you have to not have given
away i rook right if you're winning you
keep in mind you gave away a piece and I
guess there's let's see pawns are even
right now so you're down a whole piece
right because you did take it a couple
pawns when you took on you six
so so Queenie six very good Ben
this is why Ben is a grandmaster so King
up to go to f8 and now there's a fork
right oh no oh my goodness
you guys are just giving away all my
pieces I don't like it so Knight has to
take I assume because the Queen takes
there's a good move other than rook
takes Queen yes 9000 retro this is a
problem so yeah I mean he's gonna have
to give away material and he's still
gonna get made it and by the way it's
very convenient that after Bishop takes
pawn I could probably play here and win
but Knight takes defends my rook it's
easy to miss tactics like that by the
way but yeah I did not see all of this
when I played because I would have
played Knight up g5 if I saw this
because it was a slightly better move
than what I play anyway so we're nearing
the end but I wanted to see the
hourglass I'm turning into a witch now
so I wanted to show kind of the end do
not be too attached to any of this like
if you make a blunder in your position
all of a sudden is not it goes from
winning to equal who cares
keep playing it doesn't matter same
thing happens you make a blunder you're
losing your opponent makes a blunder or
whatever just you know play the position
in front of you don't play the position
you add five moves ago don't play the
position you want five moves from now
just play your position find their best
moves do not obsess over what's changed
what blunders were made like oh my
goodness I played this move I should be
stripped of my titles just do not think
this way just play the position you have
right in front of you so we ended up in
this from my gorgeous position where he
has no space we ended up in some endgame
I should not win but okay here I
actually have a good move with e5 it's a
little bit complicated but eventually it
should be good for me but here again I
had like no time I had like five less
than five minutes so it was hard for me
to calculate all the complications so I
came up with an idea
played ninety-two here and now I decided
okay I could just move my night around
and it's gonna be a draw right I can
move my night here but his King drops
here his Bishop guard this pawn I can't
do anything so in order to win I need to
penetrate his position with which piece
the answer is not the night the King
often and then game in order to win you
need to get your King active so here I
go
the problem is when I play this move
what move does it allow uh-oh so now I
have to be careful I could lose this
game imagine losing that position before
but that's what I mean you can't be too
attached to results right when I was
playing this end game I have to be just
playing this endgame I can't be thinking
oh my goodness I had more space his
knight was on h7 how did I not win this
is the most embarrassing game in my life
you can't you just no focus on the game
so I managed to avoid these thoughts
mostly but the main thing is that okay I
have a problem now his King Owen King is
gonna get in so I took this pawn and on
that front what is probably blacks best
move here yeah
penetrate with the King get the King in
so here I probably have to move my
knight because otherwise King c3 and my
Knights kind of an embarrassed piece
right and it's very complicated I
thought that it was probably drawn so at
this point I had resigned myself alright
Josh you blew in another good position
whatever it's gonna be a draw but he
surprised me with this move now of
course during the game I don't know if
this is a blunder or not but I didn't
expect this move so here I had two
options with I could play king b6 or
king c5 any guesses which I chose
I would guess qc5 is king
I don't know about pointless I mean
you're going after his pawn right but
yeah I mean I didn't want to allow King
D for right but here he has other ideas
like he can take and try to play king f4
and all this but again I wanted to keep
his King out another nice thing about
this move is that in some positions I
can threaten to play here cutting off
his Bishop and then play b5 because they
remember if he can't take the pawn with
the bishop he has to take with a pawn
what has he done for me that past a pawn
right that's what I'm gonna win the game
with a pawn but here he thought he'd
take for sure and play King here but he
surprised me again with this move g4 so
potentially this could be a nasty move
if his King gets in here but he missed
my next move and after my next move he's
basically done for but it's not an
obvious move so why not be one what are
you putting your net on the back rank
for oh you have an idea again I move
that normally you don't want to do but
you have an idea Knight c3
once Knight c3 you're not only defending
your pawn you're threatening this which
is what's important right yeah you're
good you're like 25 60 so so if Knight
c3 then it likes a black just passes I
don't know how you're gonna pass in a
position like this but say you play here
and I go Knight c3 now I'm just gonna
play B 5 and then Queen my pawn you're
gonna have no chance right he could have
played Bishop b5 here a bishop here but
okay I mean he does not have much of a
chance in drawing this endgame right
I mean his Bishop is just not good
enough so he took my pawn
it's okay I got it but what's the
problem with this I fork him King f3 and
now I do what it's not a trick question
thank you
so this key has to move away he doesn't
get to take anything mm-hmm
so he took he can go closer but it
doesn't really matter and not you and he
actually played on for a few moves King
f3 a7 takes Queen Bishop would be not a
good move King here now do I take this
pawn nah one of the things this is kind
of minor like in this position you can
probably win doing whatever you want he
just doesn't have enough for the Queen
but often pawns like this and you are
just irrelevant as well as my King gets
close to his King and my Queen gets
close to his king he has no chance right
I just want to make sure he doesn't
Queen his Jeep on so I just play closer
he's not gonna hurt me with this one
pawn
not when I have an extra Queen extra
Queens are amazing if you can get an
extra Queen I highly recommend it
you can do lots of things when you have
an extra Queen so you played here and I
gave a couple checks
I checked here I loved the Queen's of
long range - it's very useful so a few
bruises came back I just bring my King
in he goes here and he resigned after I
checked him here because if he goes back
I can check and take this or take this
or take this and he's not gonna Queen
his Jeep on so that was them but it was
nice it was actually my first win of the
tournament as Messier was it was nice to
get a win and I actually managed to win
two and a half out of the next three -
so oftentimes in a tournament once you
get your first win it's you know it
doesn't usually take me five or six
games but a tournament of this strength
I was just happy to get it so it was
nice but yeah I mean you can see how in
the opening it really matters even you
know GM level 1600 1200 it doesn't
matter you control the center occupy the
center with pawns and if your opponent
plays something like the hippo what's
the
most important thing apart from keeping
control of the center in all this don't
rush
just take your time the second I played
a semi rush move not even that rushed
all of a sudden he had play but before I
played h4 if I just maneuver mine and
Iran I mean he can't do anything
so do not rush take your time and you'll
win a lot smoother than I do